I think it is looking increasingly
difficult politically that Australia
could stay out of a war over Taiwan in
the same way that I think it would be
increasingly difficult for Japan to stay
out of a war
um it's you know these navies are going
to be integrated America is going to be
increasingly reliant on um bomber bases
in the north of Australia submarine
ports in the west of Australia
um and the politics of turning around to
America in what would be the biggest war
since 1945 and saying sorry we're
sitting this one out to me that just
seems implausible for Europeans it's a
slightly different issue but even for us
I think we're going to find it
increasingly hard to say we're sitting
this one out